okay so there's just been a massive
update on marvel's phase four and phase
five plans at comic-con hall h kevin
feige came out and from the off he said
phase four will end with black panther
wakanda forever he then started to go
through the phase five announcements and
said it will start with ant-man quantum
mania be followed by secret invasion
then guardians of the galaxy vol 3 echo
loki season 2 the marvels blade iron
heart the agatha disney plus show
daredevil born again which i'm very very
hyped at captain america the new world
order and it will culminate with the
thunderbolts interestingly dead evil
born again will be 18 episodes long
making it by far the longest disney plus
show whether it's gonna be r-rated or
not we don't know but with marvel
zombies being tvma i kind of hope that
it is anyway that's all the major
announcements so far stay locked to the
channel as we're going to be doing a
black panther wakanda forever trailer
breakdown and also going over this panel
in more depth hope to see you soon
thanks for checking in with me